para 2030 los Objetivos de Desarrollo Sostenible?
¿Hay realmente compensaciones inherentes
no compatibles con nuestro paradigma de desarrollo actual?
Pero ¿hay, tal vez, sinergias donde realmente poder acelerar el cambio?
Y ¿es realmente una agenda de personas del planeta,
que toma en serio los objetivos aspiracionales sociales y económicos
dentro de los sistemas de soporte vital en la Tierra?
Los ciudadanos de todo el mundo han comenzado a reconocer
que estamos enfrentando crecientes riesgos ambientales globales;
de hecho, un planeta estable es un prerrequisito
para tener bienestar humano en la Tierra.
Necesitamos definir un espacio operativo seguro en un sistema de Tierra estable,
y el marco de la frontera planetaria se introdujo
por la comunidad científica en 2009
para hacer exactamente eso.
Eso ha sido ampliamente aceptado en todo el mundo
en política, negocios y comunidades
como marco para el desarrollo sostenible
en el antropoceno.
Esta diapositiva realmente muestra el marco con los 9 procesos ambientales
que regulan la estabilidad del sistema terrestre,
proporcionando un espacio operativo seguro,
donde tendremos una alta probabilidad de tener un buen bienestar humano
y prosperidad y equidad.
Al movernos a la zona amarilla, entramos en una zona de incertidumbre peligrosa;
y en el rojo, tenemos alta probabilidad de cruzar puntos de inflexión
lo que podría alejarnos irreversiblemente de la capacidad del sistema terrestre
de proporcionar bienestar social y económico a la humanidad.
Hoy podemos científicamente cuantificar estos límites,
que nos proporcionan un sistema terrestre estable para la humanidad.
Pero tenemos que ir más allá
y reconocer que los Objetivos de Desarrollo Sostenible,
si realmente queremos cumplirlos seriamente,
deben ocurrir dentro de este espacio operativo seguro.
Necesitamos alcanzar los ODS dentro de los PP.
Pero queridos amigos, ni siquiera esto es suficiente.
Necesitamos reconocer que los Objetivos de Desarrollo Sostenible
están a 12 años de distancia.
Es solo un hito.
Es la diana que debemos atravesar
y acercarnos a las transformaciones
donde poder tener un buen futuro para todos los ciudadanos en la Tierra,
más de 9 mil millones,
dentro de un sistema de Tierra estable en 2050 y más allá.
Esta es una búsqueda,
y para realmente explorar esto y no solo tener opiniones al respecto,
reunimos a la comunidad científica, a los mejores pensadores y diseñadores
para desarrollar un modelo dinámico de sistemas complejos completamente nuevo,
el modelo de la Tierra-3,
basado en modelos que han existido durante los últimos 50 años.
Y aquí está.
Este es un trabajo fantástico.
Esto tiene un módulo de clima, uno de biosfera y un modelo económico global;
tiene algoritmos, tiene toda la sala de fantásticos logros.
Esto es lo que nos convierte en científicos.
(Risas)
Es decir, ¿esto es solo un hermoso trabajo?
Y me encantaría pasar toda la noche con Uds.
pero les decepcionaría.
No puedo hacerlo.
De hecho, lo único que puedo hacer es asegurarles
que esta es la primera vez que se hace.
Nadie ha tratado de combinar realmente analíticamente
los Objetivos de Desarrollo Sostenible con las fronteras planetarias.
Y pudimos encontrar patrones y tendencias realmente convergentes.
Eso nos da mucha confianza en nuestra capacidad para proyectar ahora
desarrollo económico,
uso de recursos del agua, alimentos y energía;
crecimiento poblacional, e ingresos por persona.
Sin embargo, a lo largo de estos caminos consistentes y sistémicos,
es la primera vez que tenemos una gran oportunidad
para explorar el futuro de la capacidad de alcanzar los ODS dentro de las FP.
Y ¿cómo hacemos esto?
Bueno, miren esto.
Aquí, tienen los datos que vienen del mundo real,
calibrados desde el 1970 al 2015:
100 000 puntos de datos en todo el mundo,
aprovechando la capacidad de siete regiones,
de realmente meterse en todos estos Objetivos de Desarrollo Sostenible.
Un ejemplo de cómo calibramos esto,
son los datos para los Objetivos de Desarrollo Sostenible
para la erradicación de la pobreza, la salud, la educación y la alimentación.
Y aquí tienen en las burbujas las siete regiones del mundo,
cómo ascienden hasta 2015 en nuestras observaciones empíricas
en relación al PIB per cápita,
dadas estas tendencias convergentes universales,
que nos permitieron crear regresiones.
Eso podría capacitarnos para hacer simulaciones en el futuro,
todo el tiempo hasta el 2050,
mostrando la capacidad a lo largo de las líneas aquí para alcanzar los ODS.
Esto nos dio la oportunidad de recrear varios escenarios,
probando diferentes futuros posibles:
negocios como siempre, transformaciones globales,
esquemas de inversión en negocios, diferentes opciones de gobierno,
políticas, finanzas.
Todo para explorar cómo puede verse el futuro.
en nuestra capacidad para alcanzar los ODS dentro de las FP.
Y los resultados, les puedo decir, realmente nos sorprendieron.
Y esta será la primera vez que se muestran.
En realidad, ni siquiera se debe hacer referencia fuera de esta sala.
En realidad, se presenta en dos ejes.
El eje y aquí muestra nuestra capacidad
para permanecer dentro de los límites planetarios.
Cuanto más arriba, más cerca se está del espacio operativo seguro.
En el eje x están los Objetivos de Desarrollo Sostenible;
Cuanto más a la derecha, más cumplimos los ODS.
Todos queremos estar en la esquina superior derecha,
El mundo seguro y justo para el futuro.
El punto que ven es 1980.
Estábamos en una situación en la que estábamos en un espacio operativo seguro
pero no cumpliendo con muchos de los ODS.
Aquí está la tendencia hasta el 2015.
Así que este es el mundo convencional,
que en realidad está cumpliendo con un número cada vez mayor de ODS,
sacando a millones de personas de la pobreza,
pero haciéndolo a expensas del espacio operativo seguro en la Tierra.
Ahora, este es el escenario de negocios como de costumbre, en el futuro.
Si seguimos adelante como hoy,
podremos cumplir con algunos de los ODS,
pero lo haremos a expensas de la estabilidad del sistema terrestre.
¿Y si vamos más rápido en el crecimiento económico
y realmente nos aliamos en un 1 % de aumento por año de ingresos
y un triple incluso de la economía mundial para 2050?
Eso nos daría la siguiente trayectoria.
Sí, iremos un poco más lejos en los logros de SDG,
Pero aún a costa del riesgo de desestabilizar el planeta.
Pero ¿y si realmente vamos más duro?
¿Qué pasa si aumentamos nuestra capacidad de cumplir nuestras promesas en un 30 %
en todos los sectores de la sociedad
desde el clima a nuestros acuerdos comerciales?
Un escenario más difícil nos haría ir un poco mejor,
pero aun así, estamos fallando en los ODS,
sin lograr un espacio operativo seguro para la humanidad.
Así que esto realmente nos llevó a una conclusión bastante decepcionante,
que realmente, incluso si vamos hacia los futuros convencionales,
fallaremos en los ODS y traspasaremos los límites planetarios.
Necesitamos un pensamiento radical.
Necesitamos entrar en un futuro transformador, disruptivo,
donde empezar a pensar de forma no convencional.
El diseño, el compromiso y el diálogo nos permiten identificar
cinco transformaciones que en realidad, podrían llevarnos allí.
El primero es reducir las emisiones a la mitad cada década.
a lo largo del camino científico a París,
duplicar las inversiones en energías renovables,
creando una democracia energética global,
lo que nos permitiría cumplir con varios de los ODS.
El segundo es un rápido cambio hacia sistemas alimentarios sostenibles,
invertir el 1 % anual en la intensificación sostenible
y avanzar hacia la implementación e inversión en soluciones
que ya tenemos disponibles hoy.
El tercero es realmente cambiar nuestro paradigma de desarrollo.
y aprender de muchos de los países en desarrollo
que se han trasformado muy rápido.
¿Y si pudiéramos tener un crecimiento económico como en China,
haciéndolo dentro de los parámetros ambientales
de una civilización ecológica?
En cuarto lugar, una redistribución de la riqueza.
¿Y si pudiéramos acordar que el 10 % más rico
pudiera acumular como máximo el 40 %
de los ingresos nacionales.
Eso sería una drástica redistribución de la riqueza,
¿Reformando la capacidad de equidad en todas las regiones?
Y finalmente, quinto, un aumento radical en más educación, salud,
acceso al trabajo, anticoncepción,
invirtiendo en gran medida en mujeres en todo el mundo,
lo que nos permitiría cumplir con los ODS sobre género, desigualdad,
economía y desarrollo urbano.
Si nos empeñamos en todos estos cinco,
nos daría un resultado increíble
hacia el espacio de operación seguro y justo en la Tierra.
Nos muestra que incluso con un enfoque conservador, empírico,
modelo de dinámica de sistemas complejos,
estaríamos en un estado en el que podemos pensar en transformaciones
durante los próximos 12 años y más allá.
Eso nos puede llevar al espacio operativo seguro
y cumplir objetivos aspiracionales sociales y económicos.
Esto es en realidad muy edificante,
a pesar de no movernos a lo largo de esta trayectoria.
En resumen:
tres años tras la entrega operativa de los ODS,
hay que trazar una línea
y concluir que no estamos cumpliendo nuestras promesas,
Y no solo eso, estamos corriendo riesgos
de las generaciones futuras que tienen una habilidad aún más dura,
por el riesgo de llevar el sistema terrestre
más allá de los puntos de inflexión.
De hecho, nos enfrentamos incluso al riesgo de una Tierra de invernadero,
donde socavaremos y crearemos inestabilidades geopolíticas.
Eso podría hacer la vida aún más difícil
para miles de millones de personas en la Tierra.
Esto, con toda honestidad, realmente me asusta.
Pero por eso también estoy aquí esta noche,
porque la ventana del éxito sigue abierta.
El sistema terrestre sigue siendo resiliente.
Todavía nos proporciona servicios y funciones de ecosistema.
Eso nos puede permitir una transición a un espacio operativo seguro.
Pero necesitamos un pensamiento radicalmente diferente.
Necesitamos verlo no solo como una increíble llamada de atención,
sino también como una oportunidad para el cambio transformador,
donde cambiamos de marcha
y empezamos de verdad a pensar en los ODS como una agenda transformadora
dentro de un espacio operativo seguro en la Tierra.
En otras palabras, podemos construir un mundo seguro y justo.
Solo tenemos que, real, realmente, seguir adelante con esto.
Y hagámoslo. Gracias.
(Aplausos)